freedom is a good song to come into this
segment with social media what we're
talking about companies like Facebook
and Twitter we're already taking a
beating on Wall Street in recent weeks
one factor being the slowing or
declining user numbers then came this
week's report from snapchat of its own
big drop-off in daily active users the
trend has some wondering if the ones
unstoppable trend of social media growth
might be reversing course all about
freedom here to talk about it is Lauren
good senior writer at Wired magazine she
covers personal tech and gear Lauren
welcome thanks for having me our
pleasure is 3 million active users is
what snapchat said that they lost in
this last quarter before we get into the
overall social media what does that mean
for snapchat specifically it's a good
question I mean Snap hasn't had
particularly encouraging earning reports
since it went public and I think what
people are looking at now is not just
whether or not snaps recent redesign is
the cause of this which is what the CEO
Evan Spiegel said was part of the
disruption in users we heard a lot of
rumblings about those absolutely I mean
the redesign was very poorly received in
fact snap ended up reversing some of the
design changes that it made but I think
the bigger question is whether or not
this hints that some sort of larger
social media fatigue and this is more
evidence of that you're you're hitting
on the point exactly because in order
for these companies to flourish they've
got to be used by people so have we hit
that hard stop is the saturation point
among us I think the saturation point
question is the big question right now
and when you look at the fact that
Facebook has more than 2 billion users
on its platform when you just start to
think oh my gosh how could they possibly
get any more users than that and that is
I mean that is the point right there are
only so many people in the world and
there are only so many people who are
going to want to use social media and
platforms like snapchat and Facebook so
at some point these companies and
they've start already started to do this
you need to think less about this you
know user number and think about
engagement and that's what's actually
going to matter in the long run
engagement is the amount of time of a
person spends on the site using the
service right that's correct
you know people turn away from social
media when they stop finding to be a
pleasant experience
the issues facing all these companies is
how do they for lack of a better word
police the language police the behavior
seems like a complicated question for
companies that are just try to make a
buck it is an incredibly complicated
question and I think well what you're
hinting out here may be two different
things one may be the feeling that
people get when they're using social
media if it's making them happy if it's
making them sad and there have there has
been some research that points towards
people maybe not having the greatest
experience or feeling great after using
social media and then you're also
talking about with what they're seeing
on a platform is maybe couldn't be
considered harassment could be
considered abusive could be something
that they just don't want to experience
in their digital lives we've also talked
a lot in the past couple weeks about
disinformation not even just a couple
weeks couple months and certainly since
the election just information on social
media and the role places like Facebook
and Twitter may have played in that how
is that impacting how people now view
these social media sites it depends on
how aware of it
I think people are and dissing this
information certainly is a huge topic
right now especially as you see that
earlier this week big tech companies
like Apple Facebook Google's YouTube
started to take action against
controversial figure Alex Jones and
remove some of his content from the
platform who's been known for spreading
information that would be called would
be considered disinformation and so I
think that you're going to start to see
people react to do that more strongly as
they become aware of what has actually
happened it's being wrong and then
there's being wrong with malice
we thank you for being with us thanks so
much